okay so now we have our freshly printed
website I'm going to go ahead and clean
things up a little bit so we're only
looking at what our mock-up should be
get rid of these colors and get rid of
this extra margin on the side so now I'm
going to go ahead and cut this up into a
bunch of different boxes so you can see
to start out we have three main boxes
one for our header one for the middle
image and one for the bottom images but
there's actually a lot more than just
three boxes here looking at the header
again we have two more boxes one for the
udacity you and another for our name and
title so let's cut those out
we still have our single image in the
middle here but looking at our bottom
featured work section we actually have
another box for our header and then
three more boxes around our images and
captions and you could actually keep
cutting these up into more boxes we have
another box around our images another
box around our titles another around the
URLs but my hands kind of cramping from
all that cutting so I'm just going to
stop here now as you just saw I printed
out the page and I cut it up with
scissors but obviously you could have
done any of these and it would have
worked out and you also should have
found between nine and twenty boxes
depending on how deep you went and how
much you just love drawing boxes around
things